- How you feelin'?
- [Maverick] Tell your guy,
don't get me with the feet.
- I will. That's gonna
be the best part.
I need to go viral.
Zoom in on his toes.
(group laughter)
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
I was more than happy to
take the snarky comments
about self-promotion.
I'm like that's cute.
I'm like but business is real.
- [Bob] Right.
- You know?
Your opinion's lovely.
And then what's great is, and
this is why I can't waiver from
it is a lot of the shit
that I said became true.
Because I'm tripling down
on the one thing I've had.
I've always had that
intuitive, as a 13,
as a 16-year-old I just sold my
entire baseball card collection
at the height of baseball cards
and converted into comic books
'cause I could taste the
shift and it happened.
- [Bob] That's awesome.
- And so then that's how
I built the wine business.
I built Wine Library on the back
of Australian and Spanish and
New Zealand wines while Sherry
Lehmann's than Zachy's and
Morrell's were playing
France and California.
- [Bob] Right.
- So it like it's always been
there and it will always be
there and that's...
- [Bob] Always be there
and you know what we do.
I've been in this
business a long time,
(inaudible) it's
about TV, internet.
- [Gary] You've been in it.
- But I always
focus on business.
It's number one.
- [Gary] Attention.
- All you do is
watch the consumer.
Don't get
distracted by technology.
Don't get distracted--
- [Gary] It's the same game.
- How's the consumer behavior?
What is the consumer doing?
- I'm eating my own dog food.
Like, I know how it plays out.
It's leverage.
I want the next Mark Zuckerberg
to come to me and say I'm cool
and be on the board
like this is people are
misunderstanding
what's happening.
And that's how I think
about stuff like when everybody
debates all this stuff all you
need to do is build brand with
the end consumer.
- Right.
It's money in the bank.
Always.
- Always.
- Brands win, two
things when brands win,
convenience wins.
- That's right.
- If you can figure out
how to make my life easier.
Whatever that product
is you're gonna win.
- DRock's laughing.
So I had a feeling.
It's very obvious for me to see
who's navigated careers or who's
emerging to
navigate careers and,
by the way, I actually don't
care about anything else than
those two things.
Speed is how
I correlate convenience.
You know?
And that's why ads are bad.
Ads are taking people's time
away in a world where people now
care about time so much which is
why native matters to me so much
because you're integrating
within the content and
radio so set for that.
- One of our corporate
values is urgency wins.
We start everything, if
we're gonna build something,
we start, news 24 hours, we
make them justify to take three
months to do it.
But as opposed to
trying to pull people in,
start with 24 hours.
Everything will be done 24 hours
unless you have
a damn good reason.
- The amount of money that our
potential clients are wasting in
a 2017 world is extraordinary
and it's being
poured in two places.
Television commercials and
traditional programmatic
digital inventory.
To buy programmatic on a banner
or pre-roll where you don't know
where it's actually being
deployed and the KPI's the CPM
and the creative has no idea
contextually where it's sitting
is insanity.
I just want to have that in
the back of your mind as well.
Alright, good to see you again.
Just get some light for you.
Hey guys, it's 2:10 P.M.
DRock overslept, I'm kidding.
Strategy, I should've
been recording but
a little late start.
Super fun meeting anytime you
get to go the titans of media.
It's always a lot of fun
but just trucking along.
Super productive CES.
Just a ton of business meetings,
a lot of people excited about
the PureWow deal.
Asking about that.
But just a lot of biz dev.
Some really successful meetings
with Facebook and good to see
Snapchat and just a lot of
clients and media companies and
just starting to
really get in the game.
It's reminding me very much to
when Wine Library kinda hit a
crescendo moment, probably about
2003 and four where the other
people in the game started
giving me that head nod.
Like hey, we know you're in it.
This is a very big industry.
These are billions and billions
of dollars worth companies so
took little time, even though
I started from a nice base but
I could taste it.
And it's is exciting.
I love the game.
I respect everybody
even our competitors,
people that don't believe
in us but I want to win.
I want to win
more than anything.
- Can I get a picture with you?
- Sure. Of course.
- Oh, man.
I can not believe this.
You seeing this, oh my God.
Brother, you just made my shift.
You just made all
of this worth it, man.
- Thank you man.
What's your name?
- Renzo.
Nice to meet you.
- Oh my God!
I'm way, I'm way too
excited about this man.
- Thank you, man.
- I have my best friend Luis,
he's working at the Cosmopolitan
and he said, "Hey man, you
gotta listen to this guy, man."
'Cause I seen my friend,
he's hustling and hustling.
I was yo,
I like what you're doing.
You're getting it.
And he was like you
don't understand.
You gotta listen to this guy.
He's a monster, man.
Like he's gonna
turn your life around.
- Thank you, man.
- I want you to listen
to this and ever since,
man, it's just been like--
- 'Sup guys?
- it's crazy, Gary, yo.
Oh my God!
- [Man] Are you
busy right now, brother?
- Let me take this picture.
- [Man] We just
want to take a picture.
- Yeah, okay, no problem.
- [Renzo] Oh, my God, man.
He said, VaynerMedia's here.
And I was like no way.
I was like you're gonna see him?
And he said Gary wasn't
here at the end of the day.
- That's awesome.
Let's take this.
- And I was like, dude.
Put it on my Snapchat, yeah?
- Yeah.
- Aw, man.
This is awesome, brother.
- Awesome, man.
Really nice to meet you.
- Thanks so much, man.
Appreciate you.
- Take care.
- Appreciate what you do, man.
- Yeah, no worries.
- Brother!
- How are you?
- Dude, you were so right.
You did this one
things about, on music.
- Isaac.
- [Gary] Isaac,
nice to meet you.
Hi.
- Hi.
- [Isaac] Can we
get a quick picture?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- Cool. Legend.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
Thank you, man.
Where you from?
- [Man 2] California.
- Very nice, man.
- You posted it but you did this
video like years ago and you
predicted about
this music industry...
Dude, I'm making beats right now
and you couldn't
be more right, bro.
- Thank you, man.
Good luck to you.
Good luck, take care.
How you doin'?
- Good. How are you?
- [Gary] Good, man.
What's going on?
- Life.
- (laughs) Life.
Life is going good?
- Yeah.
- What's, you want to
walk and talk a little bit?
While I get to my next thing.
We're in Aria right now?
- [DRock] We are in Aria.
- So let's get to Cosmo.
Alright, let's go
this way, right?
Yeah, but we won't...
DRock, don't film this.
He's talking to me
about important shit.
I mean you can film the
image, not the audio.
What's that, brother?
I'm gonna give you a
real good piece of advice,
I came into the game five
years ago and was already rich,
successful and a guy
and I didn't care,
I didn't care.
The work and the, chip
at it one day at a time.
Don't get crippled.
- [Baldwin] Yep.
- [Gary] Right?
- [Gary] I let it come to me.
- [Baldwin] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] When it comes to you...
- [Baldwin] It's better.
It's better.
- [Gary] You know what I mean?
So you're young and hungry and
want to fucking rip people's
skulls out of their bodies
but let this shit come to you.
Here's what I know.
I know that actions.
Yeah. We didn't
walk in a circle.
- [Baldwin] Yeah, we did.
- [Gary] No, we did not.
- [Baldwin] Yeah.
(laughs)
- [Gary] No, we did not.
- [Baldwin] That's fine,
Cosmo's over there.
- [Gary] No, we did not.
That's amazing.
Did we film that?
We walked in a circle?
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Gary] No, we did not.
- [Man 3] Yeah, we
came out right there.
- [Gary] There?
Holy shit.
- [Baldwin] The reason why
I think it's interesting...
On this side, but it's fine.
- [Gary] Take this elevator up?
- [Baldwin] Introducing
high quality content,
exactly as fast as motivational.
- [Gary] And I've scaled.
- [Baldwin] I chimed
into your live the other day,
I was like let me see
what Gary's spitting.
- I got crazy?
- [Baldwin] Look at the hashtag
plumber for seven hours a day
and I was like, okay.
- I'm trying to help.
- [Baldwin] Which is good.
Right, at scale--
- Do you know what it feels like
to have somebody call you and
say, email you and say that
they're a single mom and they
made $200 selling
eBay shit today and
it means something to them?
- [Baldwin] Yeah.
I mean that's the thing.
The way I break the world up
is 90% of the world are they're
afraid and they want to
be safe and that's okay.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Baldwin] And
everyone doesn't have to be--
- [Gary] That's exactly right.
Yep.
- [Baldwin] Then
5% of the world,
they're entrepreneurial but
they're doing it with the
ego and perception
that's driving it.
It's not true.
- [Gary] Correct.
- [Baldwin] And then
there's 5% percent I sit in,
you sit in that, designing life.
It's designed.
Life by design.
Everything I do is
'cause I want to.
There's no ego,
there's no perception,
there's no shit.
It's because this is what's
making me happy and what's
fueling this longer vision.
- [Gary] I love it.
I love it, man.
Let's keep this
conversation going.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'll see
you in New York.
- Gary.
- [Gary] Hey.
- Big fan.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- Congratulations
on your acquisition.
- [Gary] Thank you.
What's your name?
- Brian McCloud.
- [Gary] Hey Brian.
- Forbes.
- Very nice, man.
Real pleasure.
Thanks, brother.
Thank you, man.
You're welcome.
What floor?
- [Woman] 27.
- [Gary] Fuck.
Hey, we're locked out of our
room and DRock trying to get me
to do the update
from one year ago.
I'm just recording this
vertically because I know what
I'm about to say and
I just want to document.
Like, it's so obvious to
me what's gonna happen with
DailyVee and Snapchat.
Our execution in
these next 12 months,
it's gonna be so fucking crazy
what it all looks like a year
from today.
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- Maybe you'll use this
video to show the numbers.
As a matter of fact, make
sure you document my YouTube
subscribers and I'll save right
now a Snapchat story how many
story views I'm getting.
We'll literally run this video.
Put it in your
calendar right now,
a year from today we'll put this
out because what a lot of people
don't understand is it's
execution and we've put the
pieces in place
of full execution.
Right?
- [DRock] Yep.
- But the truth is I'm not
worried about how many more
followers I have on Instagram
or Snapchat or Facebook and it's
phenomenally great.
It's the impact.
It's the fact that you
can't walk fuckin' seven steps,
DRock, without
somebody saying hey.
Hey, it's pretty cool like
you've done for
my life or this and that.
When I said, and
you can clip it here,
in a year from now, it's
gonna be so fucking crazy,
it's not going to be how
many fucking followers I have,
it's how much impact I'm having
in helping
others do their thing.
'Cause I'm gonna get mine.
I'm gonna win regardless.
I was a businessman that won and
made millions before there was
the fucking documenting of
internets and blogs and things
of that nature.
I'm building an agency.
GaryVee's my side hustle.
I'm doing this for legacy.
It's brand building.
Gives me leverage for
other opportunities but
the ROI why is the tweets.
Go search my username right now
and go look at all the people
that miraculously have a better
life overnight because they're
actually selling shit that's
randomly in their house and
they have $500 go do that thing.
It's impact.
It's not how many
fucking followers,
I don't need an update
on my followers, DRock.
What do you mean it's the worst?
Where were you?
By the way,
I have a funny feeling
your key's not gonna work.
Why is your key gonna
work and mine's not?
Please, God.
(door beeps)
Yeah!
Okay, good.
Fuck, I forgot my
gel in fuckin' New Orleans.
Almost forgot my fuckin'--
- [DRock] I have some.
- [Gary] It's alright,
I don't need your gel.
Like, you can't get around here.
You know?
- [Ryan] We're probably
gonna wanna do a new front.
You tell them, you'll help him
with his if he gives us artists
to come to ours.
- No, we're gonna
do something else.
- [Ryan] What?
- We're gonna do a fuck a
front and break the whole thing.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna do a back front.
We shouldn't commit your
money like a fucking idiot.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- We're gonna fucking,
you know what I mean?
We got to break everything now.
(group laughter)
- A back front.
- We're going to MGM.
- [Ryan] Oh wait, I got an Uber.
- You did?
Cancel it.
We're here 'cause it's faster.
You got a three, a
five, a two or a one?
You got it, DRock?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Thank you.
- [Man 3] Yes sir.
- [Ryan] She, wow,
she really wants to build
her brand like that.
- Everybody does.
That's smart.
- [Ryan] Yeah, see,
I'm nervous about it.
- Can we make 2017 the year that
we actually spend a little time
together instead of giving each
other respect through hallways
at four different events a year?
Let's have a real dinner.
- We should have a real dinner.
- [Gary] Like, one time.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I want to.
I'm excited.
I'm really excited about
what you said last night, too.
I've gonna send my
assistant a message right now.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Steve] Pleasure to meet you.
- [Gary] Take care, Steve.
That would make sense.
A player.
- [Ryan] Yeah.
- I'm gonna kill Bonin.
(DRock laughs)
Yo!
- What's up, bro?
- [Gary] What up, bro?
- How you doin', bro?
- [Gary] Good, man.
- 'Sup? Ryan.
- [DRock] How you doin', boss?
(group laughter)
- [Gary] I forgot.
That's amazing.
That's the highlight of
the whole fucking trip.
Right there.
Dude,--
- Nice to see ya.
- [Gary] How are you?
Good to see you.
- How you doing?
- [Gary] Really good, man.
'Sup, my man?
- [Sean] Sean. How are you?
- How you feeling?
- [Maverick] Tell your guy,
don't get me with the feet.
- I will. That's gonna
be the best part.
I need to go viral.
Zoom in on his toes.
Yeah, you playing?
- [Maverick] Getting busy.
- Actually, you know what?
- Monday night was the first
time I played good in 12 years.
- Can you text
Tyler and say new rule,
I'm being dead serious,
CES, South-by, Cannes--
- Basketball.
- Basketball game.
- You and I.
- Yes, and then we'll gather up.
Ryan likes to shoot
from the outside.
Have a good night.
100, that'd be fun.
- By the way, that's a
real thing he just said,
right there.
You're not appreciating it.
And if Staphon's
following Bonin,
Staphon can play a little.
Like 1 for 13 in the field but--
- That's a real
thing he just said.
All the events,--
- That's a great idea.
Just like you guys have
that party last night.
That'd be fun!
And it'll become a whole thing.
- That's the best thing, man.
Everyone will want to do that.
And you'll bring LeBron.
(group laughter)
- I'll bring Chris and Draymond.
A run, every time we're
together for one of these--
- And then if God forbid if I
score on Draymond we'll just
play it on loop on
all social for life.
- After he kicked your ass.
- Oh my God.
He's the best.
- He's the best but hooping.
- Done.
- Is he gonna
write that shit down?
- [DRock] I got it.
I'm recording it.
- [Gary] Rick, you
know what's crazy?
That people for some reason
still haven't figured it out.
This isn't Bravo.
This isn't MTV.
You're fully in control.
- [Bonin] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, you
decide what you want.
- Practice, you make
the first episode,
it's good enough you put it out.
Plus, the other thing is I
actually was just saying this to
Pittman who Ryan
used to work with,
when there's that much
volume, you're not crippled by,
we just did an
interview together.
Sometimes it's one clip, when I
went crazy and compared Twitter
to Ricky Rubio,
that's the moment.
You haven't seen that yet?
- [Ryan] What's the comp there?
- The comp was that Twitter
lost it's way because it didn't
innovate for five years.
Just like Ricky Rubio didn't
develop his shot and then I got
a little crazy and said if Ricky
Rubio was working on jumpshot
during the summer instead of
going to Ibiza and banging
chicks he would have won.
And so it became
this whole thing.
Twitter was banging chicks.
Rule number one,
nothing matters.
If you really take a step back,
99% of shit doesn't matter and
how do you outsource?
So, for example I produce
more content than anybody,
it's just that I
figured out at a macro,
oh, right, I'll just
make him follow me.
Everything's being collected.
Everything's being edited.
Now, I do have to
take time to watch it.
You know, sometimes there's a
subtlety so there's
a little allocation.
But it's also, you
know how this is,
and listen, you didn't
build a business by accident.
This I know is
important at this moment.
- [Richelieu] I built
it in Long Island,
not in Vegas.
- That's right.
- [Richelieu] You guys
are building it in Vegas,
(inaudible)
that's what I learned.
- [Gary] Listen, I think,
especially the truth of your
story is so fucking real but I'm
so excited about that brand part
but in the short term the one
thing we've consistently done
for a couple small pharma
companies out of Philly and
things of that nature, I know we
can sell at Walmart and Target.
I'm very
confident so I'm excited.
I think we will
hold our fucking own.
I love ya.
- [Bonin] But we do need
Marcus and his business.
- [Gary] Oh, shit.
I'm so glad I get to see you.
You look ridiculous.
What were you sleepin'?
I love you, man.
Where you going?
- I was out late last night.
Look at this, I'm gonna
take a picture of this.
- I just took the same picture.
- [Gary] You did?
- [Man 5] I was just like...
- [Gary] Look at
these cool kids.
So what's up?
- 'Sup, bro?
- [Gary] Who's gonna
win the NBA finals?
- I have no idea.
- [Gary] Ooh, I like that.
- Because right now
it's Wild Card Weekend.
No one gives a shit
about NBA right now.
It's all about the NFL.
- I hate all that.
- By the way, you took me off
before I could say you're the
only person who
doesn't give a fuck
'cause the Jets aren't playing.
(group laughter)
- It's true.
You know I'm not
even gonna watch.
Not even gonna watch.
Good to see ya.
How's it going?
Good?
- Good.
- [Gary] I love you.
See you later.
No, that's not the case and
it could be
seven people, Claude.
We're not pandering to this.
Everything, everything in my
life is on the
record and that's that.
Like, we're running a business.
We're running a
business, Claude.
I mean running a business.
You know?
It's like, no, I'm
not saying it to you.
I'm saying it to the world.
Like, what do you
think is happening?
("Winners Circle" by F. Mills)
How are you?
- Good.
- Yeah.
Going ot Seattle.
Yo, yo, yo!
It's all family.
That was so fun to
run in to the team.
Love it.
- [Man 6] We're
going to Air Alaska, right?
- [DRock] Yes. Air Alaska.
- Air Alaska?
Oh, weird.
Fuck, man, I'm tired.
(crosstalk)